did you watch the paralympics when it
was on in beijing
inspirational or inspiring global event
about three people saw it it would
appear
i don't know how to describe it to
people that didn't see the paralympics
it's sort of like the paralympics it's
sort of like a children's book where all
the broken toys have a picnic
yes i voted for hillary clinton of
course i did
i voted for her because i liked what she
said
vastly better than i liked what he said
but to be honest with you at that point
that [ __ ] was like watching darth vader
do the i have a dream speech
i think we're all sick of this [ __ ]
though i mean the corona is kind of like
the check engine light
you know when you first hear about it
you're like damn this is terrifying then
after a while like [ __ ] i gotta get to
work
this is too much [ __ ] is like
it's the wheels on the car you
understand like if you have a
beamer and you have a benz and you go
out and you look at both of them 19
for uh 2007 bends 2007 beamer you look
at them both
and and if the salesman comes up and
goes hey how are you
oh listen i have a wonderful car here
and you go well what's the what's some
of the
features of the car why should i buy it
because it has wheels
what [ __ ] that's what a [ __ ] is
you gotta let a [ __ ] know that look i'm
gonna tell you something
i wanna [ __ ] you you stop stop trying to
hide
that we want to [ __ ] that's the problem
we have fellas we want to [ __ ]
anyway it's like drinking water when
you're thirsty
and she's doing she's doing common core
math she brought home new math that's
what they want us to do i don't even
know what this math is
and they're like here's a new one you're
like oh great i get to watch a 40-minute
youtube video on common core math
and it's not like the old math was doing
bad it's it's doing great it's not like
we're getting incorrect change
everywhere
and we're just sitting there like this
stupid old math wish new math would come
along
i told my wife it's a long way to get to
the same
thing it would be if you came to my
house
and you knocked on the front door and
you're like can i come in and i was like
could you
walk around and come in through the back
door and you would be like does the
front door
not work and it's like it works it works
fine i use it
most people still use it but the new way
is to go
jump the fence come in the back
and then meet me back here
i'm not racist i look at racism the same
way i look at nickelback
you know yeah you know it's
uh it's fun to joke about but uh you
never want to see it live
you you you don't understand there's an
underground
[ __ ] fury towards the fact that you
are running [ __ ] but you're not you're
sharks who take their own teeth out and
let
tuna run the ocean and then tuna be like
hey girl we running the ocean
tuna wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute let me finish let me finish
and then it's like once they start
looking for
because the ecosystem's [ __ ] up
because all the sharks
because tunas have no teeth
the tuna are sitting around once they
run the ocean now they're sitting around
talking about
damn ain't no good sharks out there
where's the sharks to make this ocean
what it's supposed to be
i don't even know how to be a [ __ ]
tuna fish unless sharks are being sharks
so y'all want to run the ocean and still
be tuna you can't do it
now [ __ ] like this screaming
[ __ ] like me screaming
it's because i look at him like the
enemy because i'm trying to help
[ __ ]
be strategic and be happy because if i'm
happy
everybody around me gonna be [ __ ]
happy everybody if you're happy
if a woman's happy it can't be like that
you bleed every month for no reason
you have babies you sit down to pee your
god made you miserable that's the same
way i look at people laugh
who got nah got upset about you know
michael sam the gay football player
kissing his boyfriend when he got
drafted everybody [ __ ] moaning and
complaining it's like dude you know what
that's what you get for watching the
draft
all right now once again
what kind of a [ __ ] loser just
sits there watching round after round
the jets are up next
i think they need a quarterback do they
need they need to approve the defensive
line
dude that's like that's like going to a
graduation ceremony where you don't know
anybody who's graduating
it's just [ __ ] sitting there my
friend just got dumped so i took him out
tried to wing man him meet some ladies
for him didn't go too well you know he
got
upset he's like screw this let's go to a
strip club
i don't get that logic you know to me
that's like going fishing not catching
anything and being like screw this let's
go to the aquarium
same thing
[Music]
they're so unconsciously emotional
that our logic is so being logical is
such a deliberate thing
you're fighting it's almost like you're
you're you're upset
and trying to convince a a shark not to
eat
a [ __ ] uh penguin a pink as a shark a
shark not to eat up
chum that's what you got to do imagine
what you had to do if you spoke shark
and said listen man you cannot eat this
chum what would you have to go through
and the sharks sitting there going
what am i supposed to eat then you go
[ __ ] listen shut the [ __ ] up shark
i'ma tell you that's what you gotta do
she see what it is
she's comfortable dude she doesn't like
you anymore and she doesn't care if you
like her
y'all are in love it's us two people
have father no that's what i'm [ __ ]
saying you know my situation
specifically and that's not the truth no
no no listen to me dude i'm not saying
that i'm saying that that's what she
thinks
she's she's thinking typical and you're
not
fighting the typical [ __ ] hard enough
i'm telling you it's hard core dude
what she's saying here is hard core you
got to be
[ __ ] mean whenever
the cops gunned down the innocent black
man
they always say the same things man they
only say the same thing it's like well
it's not most cops
it's just a few bad apples
it's just a few bad apples bad apple
that's a lovely name for murderer
it's like how'd they get that one bad
apple that almost sounds nice
i mean i've had a bad apple
it was tart but it didn't choke me out
how do you give how do you give uh how
do you give a girl a 50 50
uh how do you have a 50 relationship you
alternate it to it's effort
everybody has to put in some effort to
really alternate so what happens
if you know what somebody has a good day
and somebody has a baby
you know why it's just like you and you
do very classic things like
why are you yelling why are you throwing
pins
if that's what girls do you try to take
and this is the last bastion of madness
is our anger is our physical
imposingness such a passive
is the last thing that they're trying to
[ __ ] take
because they know if they can figure out
a way to take the fact that we can punch
them through a wall
they would take that and that would be
the final
the final frontier is to take
testosterone
the we like testosterone yeah
the bear salmon oh that's scenario it's
the scenario yeah it's just like it's
like working in a in a
way it's like working in a in a in a in
a workplace
business a business office right and men
working with women is is
just like bear working with salmon
dipped in honey
and the salmon comes in and starts
talking to the bear about all kind of
stupid [ __ ]
hello bear hello jim the bear he's like
i just want to eat this [ __ ] but the
fact is
i want to eat this fish
[ __ ] fish and every day i'm
going against my entire nature just like
we're working together now and i'm like
put your titties out but that's it's
like
because of the dynamic you can go you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] but you don't work for
me so there's no power move so get out
but but at work a guy wants to do if you
came to work with those titties right
i can't i'm not even wearing a seductive
top
lavender something about you right if i
[ __ ] if you come to work with those
tits right yes
and and i and and you're you're a salmon
dipped in honey right now okay
so i'm sitting here like [ __ ] and you're
telling me [ __ ]
and you're you're not asking me [ __ ]
you're not get you're telling me [ __ ]
you're like hey this is what i like this
is what i'm going to do this is blah
blah
and blah and then one day i go
you know that honey looks good though
and you go oh my god oh my god you're
harassing me
oh my god i'm going to write you up and
talk to the [ __ ] supervisor
i can't stand it anymore and it's an
unfair thing that you're doing to your
bear claws off my fins
keep your [ __ ] honey out of my face
[ __ ]
work in the basement